[Music]
um so hello everyone this is echo and
today I'm going to introduce this our
package named plankton to you and show
you how you can make a website using our
markdown in this block down package so
first of all um if you don't have any
experience with building websites I
think that is great because you just
need to follow a few simple steps and
you will have a website up and running
in just a few minutes so that it if you
don't have any experience and I would
say congratulations you my many things
to worry about but if you do if you do
haven't some experience with building
websites I think it'll probably take you
several days to get started because
there are a few more things to consider
for example if you have an existing
website and you want to migrate you
plunk down that meant that might take
some time I will talk about that later
in in this webinar and the second thing
is that you may need to spend a huge
time a huge amount of time tweaking your
website themes like Styles yes is
templates and so on and that is just
because you know all these technologies
you know how to tweak CSS you know how
to like write HTML and if you don't know
you just use the default template and
you can start writing your content but
if you do yeah yeah I think you will be
in some trouble
anyway mmm I just want you to show you a
quick test whether you
any website experience if at this moment
you are smiling at this slide in front
of your computer I think you you you you
do have some experience with like HTML
and web server in web website so if you
if you can record recognize what what
these t-shirts mean and I think it'll
probably take a few days for you to get
started with plunk down so yeah
you may think plot on another our
package why yet another tool if you
judge block down from the appearance of
the websites that it creates you may
think what's the point of yet another
tool for building websites since we have
got plenty of tools like I guess the
most famous one is WordPress or
sometimes some people may use like
Tumblr or media medium.com so we have
got planned tools and for all of these
website tools we can create pretty much
everything we want for example for a
website you may have a navigation menu
sidebar the content of your posts or the
footer header and so on and if you just
look at the websites that belakang
creates the appearance looks similar but
there are some fundamental differences
between block down and all these
existing tools so first of all so
plantain is an hour package based on two
things first is our markdown and
actually our Markham and bucum I will
talk about that in detail later and the
second thing is Hugo so Hugo is static
website generator and which I will show
you the reasons why I chose Hugo in a
minute so for our knock down the
there are many advantages of using our
Markham for example it is the syntax of
Martin is very simple or actually it is
relatively simple because we originally
it was very very simple but later we
added a lot of things to the the syntax
in our mark now and one thing that I
hope you can remember is that the
simpler syntax is the more part the more
portable your document is for example if
your if you have got a simple are
markdown document you are not tied to a
specific output format for example isn't
it's not only for HTML output imagine
your you can you will be able to convert
your like blog posts or any web pages to
PDF Word or ebooks very easy and that is
because we use another tool called pen
doc under the under the hood so so
thanks to pen doc we can convert a
single our markdown document to many
other document formats and if you use
our Martin is not only very convenient
for you to maintain your documents but
all of your documents are more
reproducible so because you don't have
to cut and paste anything in the output
you just write the source document and
compile the source documents to get the
output documents so in terms of the
markdown features you can use most of
the most of the teachers of Martin if
you are familiar with our Moroccan and I
want to emphasize here is that besides
the traditional features of our markdown
like you can write paragraphs section
headings numbered lists or unnumbered
list plot quotes math expressions tables
images footnotes bibliography or
citations besides all of these features
you can act
use some additional features in in the
book dumb package just in case you don't
know anything about poke down I will
show you quickly um the the book time
package so the book time package was
actually designed to write books and if
you have never heard this packet before
there herself free book named after
books and technical documents with our
mock down you can read it online for
free and you can download a free pdf and
I don't want to show you the full book
but I I just want you to read at least
the it's the second chapter of the book
down book this is where you can know
what you can do in additional in
addition to the traditional American
syntax there is a lot of other things
that you can do with the book now
markdown syntax for example you can
write equations you can number them and
you can reference the equations you can
actually also write things like theorems
in proofs in are marked on so that is a
very convenient I think so of course you
can generate figures and Capo's you can
assign captions to your figures example
figure two point one here in there we
can refer to these figures in the body
of your document it cross reference them
similarly or tables you can also have
table captions and of course you can do
a bibliography and citations so just a
lot of a lot more are markdown features
and use HTML widgets which I will show
you examples later
you can you can have some interactive
widgets on your web pages so that is the
some of the book down features so that
means it will be very convenient for you
to write technical pages or web pages so
there is our Martin and the other thing
is Hugo's Hugo is is that free and open
source package written in the code
language the main the main reason that
the many reasons that I chose Hugo is
the back end up locked on by default is
that it is very easy to install it they
it is just a single binary that you
download from the Hebrew website and
there is nothing else no dependencies so
I wrote a helper function implant
unnamed install Hugo's so just simply
call this function and you have Hugo
installed and the second reason is that
Hugo is lightning fast and that it is
the main reason why I switched my own
websites to Hugo from Jacob so I have
about I have nearly a thousand blog
posts over the 10 years and I found it
just like too slow to compile my
websites you know using Jacko it often
took me like almost 1 minute to preview
my website locally that is just way too
slow and after I switched to Hugo it it
typically it takes about a second to
compile a thousand pages so I was very
happy with that so it is very fast to
build your website and Hugo is actually
a general-purpose website framework it
is not only for blocks you can build
many types of websites using Hugo so you
might have used other websites
shows like we're transmitted medium.com
tumblr blogger.com
so you may ask why not all of these
tools in the keys thing missing in these
tools is armour done so basically there
is no arm rock down support in these
tools and even if you have any
experience with using these tools I
think you know that even the basic math
support is often metouch none exist or
the support is very awkward but in
Armour on the support form math
expressions is very natural it's
basically the latex index and there's
there are a lot of benefits of using
static static websites compared to
dynamic websites all of these tools like
WordPress these tools are for dynamic
websites and they have to like on the
server side there has to be like a
server-side language like PHP and there
has to be databases but for static
websites like the website spewed from
hugo your website is completely static
and it's basically a folder of files and
there's no other dependencies like a
server-side language or or databases
basically so you basically you will get
a bunch of static HTML files and CSS
files javascript files and just a bunch
of files and you can upload these files
anywhere and they will just work there
and this they're the set up for on the
server side is typically very simple
there's no need to just install PHP or
databases and you don't have to login or
using or use password on your website
because simply because all these files
are static there's nothing there's
nowhere to login and that means your
website will whoa
be more secure so because you don't you
don't have any passwords for for any
hackers to steal in your your static
website will also work locally and was
very easy and even if you don't have
internet access you will still be able
to view your website locally and because
all these files are static typically
your website will be very fast to visit
because there's there will not be any
computation made it on the server side
and it's also very easy to speed up your
website you're using a technology named
CDN which stands for content delivery
network that basically means you your
all of your static files can be copied
to a servers worldwide example there
might be a server in like Los Angeles on
the west coast it might be a brown on
the East Coast New York so so everybody
can have fast access to your website
because your website is just consists of
static files that can be copied to many
places and just to talk about some
personal experience with different types
of websites so I have been blogging
since 2005 and I've used several PHP
applications before including WordPress
but I have I had never felt I'd truly
own website until I switched to static
websites because for example I when I
was using WordPress it is open source
but it is still a big black box to me
and it was difficult for me to maintain
because there there are many other
things to consider like PHP databases
and after I switch to static websites I
can see on my website is just basically
some static files that's I
I can see locally on my computer
whenever I need to move my website to
another place I just copy all of these
static files to that server and I'm done
and that makes me feel oh I own actually
own this website because my website it's
nothing but this folder of static files
so talking about static site generators
and there are many other static web site
generator readers as well
the most famous one might be a jackal so
it is a generator written in Ruby so as
I said checker was too slow for me and
the I I didn't really enjoy that
dependency hell because it's a ruby gem
and there's it has a lot of dependencies
so which makes it more difficult to
install but we will support Jericho even
block down anyway in the future so we
have also heard some good words about
hex oh and if you have used that I would
like to know what you think about what
do what you think about it and we will
also try to support him in the future as
well so unless you have strong reasons
to go with other generators and if you
do have these reasons I'd love to know
them and I would recommend you to stay
with Hugo so sometimes I feel just I'm
just like an arm virus because injecting
are markdown to many other tools like
like Hugo so whenever eyes I see a
wonderful tool like like you go I was
thinking to myself how about adding
armor down to this so that is how block
down was born
so if you want to get started with plot
down is actually pretty simple you you
don't have to use our studio but for
this webinar I will use ask you do for
demos so basically if you use our studio
you just create a new empty project and
if you don't use our studio you just
change your working directory to an
empty directory using the function set
WD so after after you are under an empty
directory you can install the plot time
package from github using dev tools
instant github so okay installed
Platinum package from github there is
only one function that you need to call
to create new websites which is the new
site function in blotter so in if you
are if you are brave enough and there
you are using a daily version of our
studio you can actually create a new
website project using the menu file in
new project and I will show you in a
minute how you could do that so before I
show you a real website let me just give
you a quick overview of the structure of
a typical hugo website so so typically a
hugo website consists of a config file
and then a couple of folders so there
will be the main directory that you will
be working under is the content
directory so that is where you put all
of your markdown or armor and sauce
documents so that is the content of your
website for example you may have
about Paige so which is which could be a
markdown file and about dot MD and you
may also have a post directory for all
of your blog posts and under this post
directory you may have a series of blog
posts in markdown cows or our markdown
files and there will be themes directory
where you you could
Hugo themes now I will show you a couple
of themes in a minute and there will be
also be a static directory and that is
where you put all of your static files
like images or CSS files JavaScript
files and all of all of these files will
be copied to the public directory when
Hugo views your website and for the
public directory this is basically the
generated website that can be uploaded
to any web server for example you can
upload all all of these files under the
public directory to net by github pages
or Amazon s3 and you will you will have
your static website up and running so
basically all the source files under the
content directory in all the static
files under the static directory will be
rendered to the public directory so the
public directory is what you will
publish and deploy and then in terms of
the individual pages or posts they are
either a markdown file or an arm öktem
file and I think most of you must be
familiar with the structure of an
armored-car document so basically in the
beginning you have some yellow metadata
where you specify things like the title
author and date appear document and then
you'll start writing the body of your
document so now I'm going to show you
some quick examples so that said you can
you can either create an empty project
in in our studio and use the function
new site to create a new website or if
you are using a daily version of our
studio you can actually create a website
project directory directly from the
front from this wizard so I would just
use the website project here so I will
click website using block down there now
choose a directory named example say
cast lockdown and for now I'm just using
the default theme which is called
Hugo lithium theme so we'll use the
default theme and I would create the
directory tensed block down under the
documents directory here so open that
website project in a new session I will
say create project and then I have a new
website project here so if I go to My
Documents folder I will see a new
directory named Tesla done so under this
case brought down directory I have a
couple of files and directories like
like what I just mentioned to you the
content directory the static directory
themes directory in the config file so
when I built this website you will see a
new directory named
so for every Cuba website typically
there will be a config file named config
that's a tunnel your mmm so yeah it
doesn't matter if you are not familiar
with tunnel it's very similar to yellow
so even if um you if you have never
heard of it before
thank you will be able to guess what
these options actually mean so when you
open a new website project and if you
have installed the Platinum package and
you are using a recent version of our
studio it doesn't have to be the daily
version of our studio just a recent
release version of our studio you will
see some errands in blonde town from the
eddies many you can see the areas like
new post website update metadata so for
now I'm going to use the serve sites
Eddie you can click that adding blog
down will just compile my Meg website
and start a local server and show the
websites in the ass to do viewer so you
can see now I have got a new website up
and running so there are some sample
posts in there in the default example
some are just meaningless here is a
here's an arm at an example so let's go
to the source directory so as I said we
we built this website there will be a
new public directory so that there is
where you go our renders your website
and the directory that will you will be
working on
is most likely the the content directory
so you go to content directory you have
you will see some pages like a about
page and it will also see a post
directory you don't have to follow this
structure under the constant directory
you can have arbitrary structure here
you can have any subdirectories under
the content directory you can have any
number of top-level markdown files or
are marked uncle Skeeter so I just want
to show you the source of the posts like
T like the are markdown cost there is a
source file name R - I'm not an MD with
a date prefix so there is the source of
this post hello armonica so see after
you you could have used the server-side
air in soon it's the the website in your
ask YouTube viewer will be listening to
changes in any of your source files like
I can I can update anything here so for
example I can add a new section so all
you need to do from now on is to it is
just write your content and then save it
see if that clicks study of this
document and we'll we know that there
are changes in your source directory and
it will automatically recompile your
website and refresh the page in ask
YouTube viewer so the I think that is
then it's very convenient
you don't have to take any patterns like
neatly stagnant or build these websites
all you have to do is to update your
document and save it and that's it so
instead you can use some okay Martin
features like you can you can assign
like figure captions to your our plants
example here I'm using the new chunk
option figured cap that basically means
the caption of this so then I will have
the figure caption and it is also number
as the figure number one so since I have
a chunk label hi for for this code chunk
and can refer to this figure using the
book ton syntax backslash and wrath in
parenthesis followed by the label of
these figures so that you can see figure
one from the figure 1 on the page so
well see this is my personal favorite
pie chart that shows you the like the
sky the sunny side of the pyramid and
shady side of the pyramid now I hope you
can enjoy this default example so
besides figures and tables you can come
play with HTML widgets so I will just
show you a simple widget of data tables
using the package named Petey so I can
add a code chunk to my pop boxed in I
would say here is the et package and
then I will save it in plot down
automatically
reboot my website and refresh this page
now you have a date table on your
website and it is interactive and you
can use any other HTML widgets like
leaflet or or packages like that so that
is what you can do with Martin in
lockdown so that is the default example
so that the default theme Hugo Elysium
is a very very simple and minimal theme
and that is also the same I'm using for
my own website of course you can use
many others things from Hugo so I didn't
let me let me just show you the possible
reuse that you can even you may use with
he goes if you go to the website the he
goes themes website theme start go Hugo
don't I owe you see there are a lot of
themes contributed from Hugo users you
can take your favorite theme here and
pass the address tube to the new new
site function in block down in you you
you will have a website using the new
theme let me show you some examples so
the ghost writer theme is also a minimal
same so let's
let's create a new website project again
using a different thing so I'm still
using this wizard website using plot on
now I'm creating a website under a new
directory let's test cost and here in
this build
Hugo theme and change the default theme
to - that - the ghostwriter theme I'll
open the project in a new session create
project then now I've got a new another
website using a different theme again I
just click the add in serve site so now
you can see still some so that the posts
are pretty much the same like Hello
I've seen it before but the theme is
very different now so that is the ghost
writer thing and of course we can use
other fancier things so if you are if
you are in the act amia I strongly
recommend this Hugo academic theme this
is this is very good for you to show you
your personal profile especially when
you have some like you have some courses
to teach you have some publications
ego damn it you can change the theme -
you go to academic then create a new
project
in Surfside okay so now you've got
another thing which looks like this so
basically you can have your like picture
here your name your job job or your an
affiliation your biography education
publications your talks you can still
write blog posts your projects your the
courses that you teach your contact and
information and I think the this theme
is very good for people working in the
academia so you can you can by default
the configuration file will be open so
the computer configuration files config
dot Tom so as I said even you have even
if you are not familiar with Tamil you
can probably figure out some of what
some of these options actually mean
programmable title means that the title
of your website you can certainly change
that to like for example my cool website
and you can save it and now you can see
the title has changed to my cool website
and of course you can change your name
like let's change that to my own name
and change my role I'm a software
engineer and studio save that now you
can see the name is change to my to my
name and my role and my application so
that is how you can update your website
and this theme is also very
responsive meaning that if the page
width is very small example if you are
reading this page on your mobile phone
the the style will change according to
the available width so for example the
menu is collapsed here under this icon
when the screen is too it's very narrow
but when there's like when there's
enough space to show everything for
example your your profile image then
that then the style will be slightly
different so that is the academic theme
let me show you one more thing just in
case you you look you love fancier
themes so the last thing it's the last
theme is named tranquil pig theme
again Surfside okay so that is how this
tank will pick theme looks like it's
basically there's a side bar and then
there's the list of posts and for for
every single post you can assign a
header image or some nail so for example
you can see yeah like a header image for
this post and get Steven thumbnail
images for the rest of the posts and it
is also responsive so when the page is
relatively narrow can see the sidebar is
collapsed into a list of items it can be
use pretty much anything you can you can
find from the Hugo's themes website but
my personal advice is that in the
beginning I don't recommend you to use
very fancy or complicated themes i I
would recommend you to spend more time
on creating the content of your website
instead of wrestling with CSS or
JavaScript files so I know you will not
listen to me
but I want to mention this anyway so no
matter how fancy your current theme is
you will you will surely be tired of
that fancy thin sunday so that is just
my own experience I have used a lot of
themes including WordPress themes in the
past and eventually I just I converge to
this very minimal thing Hugo Hugo Latham
theme so it's basically there is a
header then there's the content of your
page and then there's the footer so that
is just a very very very minimal theme
and at that moment I'm very happy with
this I mean
there's nothing fancy but this makes me
feel that I can focus on writing my
content instead of wrestling with the
theme forever so I also want to mention
some some of the internals of block down
so basically as I said lockdown is
pretty much the combination of Hugo and
our markdown so but for Hugo it can only
process markdown files using another
Martin engine named Black Friday we can
know more about Black Friday from the
Hugo website it so Hugo does not use pen
doc so that is pretty much the whole
motivation of block down we want to use
pendeks markdown syntax
you said Blanc Friday's and black
Fridays so the the way that Martin works
is that we will compile your armor down
files to HTML files and the past results
- Hugo and Hugo will pick the output
output from armor and pen doc and build
the website so it will basically bypass
the mountain engine in Hugo and there
are a few helper functions in this
package says I'm I have already
mentioned the new side function which
you can create a new website potentially
using a different theme other than that
the default theme so if you have not
installed Hugo before you can use the
install hugo function and if you want to
install an additional thing you can use
the install theme function and we if you
want to automatically reboot in real lqr
with your website can use the Surfside
function or equivalent equivalently
using our studio add-in surf site and
there's also a new post function which
is I think this is
very handy the new post function can
create a new blog post for you and it
let me show you a quick example of a new
post function so basically you can
either use that function or they add in
named new post so if you click this new
post adding you can just fill out all
the information related to your post for
example or you can say hello blog down
and you can choose the date of that post
and you can decide the subject
subdirectory to put that post and you
can change the final name if you want
and there are many other things for
YouTube trick and you can interactively
interactively
select categories or tags and of course
you can add new categories by just
typing here and then you can add a new
category there and you can also select
tags there and then you can decide
whether you want your you want your post
to be Martin McDonagh file then you can
click done in important will called a
function new post to create a new post
and open that automatically in our
studios you know you can just start
writing the content of your blog post
and I think I think that that one is
very useful so in terms of the Art
Studio IDE support we have the arrays
and there's only one adding that I
didn't mention which is the adding named
update metadata so this is for you to
change the metadata for example
sometimes you may want to
change the information about your post
like I want to delete a category here so
I just deleted it and then I hit done
you can see under the categories option
I only have one category now so that is
the updates metadata
in typically your workflow will be
something like you open your website
project and you click the Surfside
add-in and then you start writing your
posts or revise your code pages or post
and all you have to do is to just you're
right and save and then your website
will be automatically pretty nervous to
do viewer so if you have already got
website and you have to migrate to Hugo
for example if you had a Jaco website
you have I recommend you to go to that
he goes themes website and then pick a
theme that you like and then basically
the rest of things you need to do is to
copy or mock down pages and posts to the
new website and then clean up probably
you need to clean up the young moment
data of your old pages and just to give
you an idea of how difficult that is
so I it took me five hours in total to
migrate simply statistics Blanc from
Jacko to Hugo and I don't think that is
very bad so if you have a theme that you
like from the Hugo websites good I don't
think it will take very long for you to
migrate from check out you go otherwise
you will have to rewrite your theme
using the new Hugo syntax and I think
that of it that would take a lot of time
and if you have a wordpress website I
recommend you to convert you your
website to Jaco first and then go
from Jayco to cuba and there's a very
convenient tool named X 8 WP which is a
Python tool and basically there are
instructions on the website of X 0 WP
basically you just export your wordpress
posts to xml and use command line to
convert wordpress posts posts to
markdown files and after you have built
your website you need to publish it so
there are many many possibilities to
publish it and i will only mention one
day i know some of you might be familiar
with github pages but I don't think the
github pages is still a good option
compared to a new way a new approach a
new service named nanofied so basically
I would say Natalie PI is the new and
much more flexible github pages and just
do just a disclaimer Natalie if I didn't
pay me to say this but I really loved
their serve service so Natalie Phi has
Hugo support on their server so
basically you only have to upload your
you only have to push your source files
to a github repository and then connect
connect your net by account with your
github repository and then in the future
whenever you push to github then if I
will automatically rebuild your website
and you know it also provides free CD
and content delivery network which means
your website will be very fast to visit
and you can bind your custom domain name
for free and it also provides free is to
PS so remember if you use WordPress if
you use wordpress.com you have to pay if
you want to find your custom domain and
then if I also provides flexible
redirect rules which means you can
redirect any of your files or
directories to
another website and the thing that I
personally like most is the thing called
a continuous deployment which is I have
actually mentioned that which basically
means you can just push to github and
network firewall just continuously build
your website and it also if you care
about collaborations on your website it
also has a very nice speech feature and
that is it provides a unique preview URL
for each github pull request so if
you're if you host your website on
github and someone sends you a pull
request and then magnifier will
automatically build this pull request
and show you a unique URL which you can
find under this green check mark here so
if you open this I link this is actually
a preview of your website and you can
see what's this fool has looks like here
before you merge it so if this if the
new post looks good to you you can just
hit the merge button on github to merge
that a new cost into your website and I
think that that is very very handy and
if you I'm not going to talk about our
pine for in detail but in case you need
any technical help or you need a free
start on me domain something dot our
bind on Io you can go to this github
organization it has come slash carbine
you can seek for some technical help
there so basically this organization is
the goal of this organization is that we
want to we want to help you set up your
website and we hope you could help
someone else in the future after you
have learned more about log
in all these web technologies so this is
a website community where we can show
the source the countries of your
websites and you can you can help other
people set set up their own website so
one thing that I want to emphasize is
that this organization is still very
young and we I don't want you to treat
anything about it at this moment because
and we are still waiting for more
volunteers to join our bind so so lastly
I want to talk about something that is
not technical at all so why should you
have websites so basically there is a
plantain book which is still incomplete
and in the in a very beginning of that
book I said I wear therefore I am so
that basically means you don't exist if
you don't have a website that might be a
little exaggerative but I think it's
still true to some extent so basically I
the when you have a website you can
share what you have learned with other
people and more importantly you can
share what you have learned with your
future self and I find this very useful
to master because sometimes I might have
learned some tricks and later I will I
will forget of them and if I write them
down in on my own websites so sometimes
I will go back to my own website and and
read my old posts again to learn the
tricks that I I have I learned four so
for me I start blogging since 2005 so
that was like twelve years ago so I of
course I first started writing a blog
post in Chinese because I'm reasoning
from China and you can I know most of
you cannot read any of these characters
here because there
but at least you can you can see the
dates all these posts you can see my
very first post was in 2005 in January
the 7th and I have written blog posts
maybe like 700 or 800 blog posts in
Chinese and maybe 200 in English and I
started my English blog in 2007 and I
can I can tell you that the most
important lesson that I learned so
basically I can summarize that as tweet
and forget right and remember so I have
to admit that I wrote a large amount of
garbage and push it over the 10 years
but I I tend to think more deeply when I
see here and write something then when I
talk or read so so among all the garbage
that I produced on my website there
occasionally there might be a jam or two
sometimes I might come up with some
ideas that later
later they will turn out to be actually
very useful see if you are still not
convinced that you should write
something on your website I would reckon
I would strongly recommend you to rate
book musing ourselves to death so I just
finished reading this book a couple of
days ago and I was like I asked you it
totally blew my mind I just feel like it
is so important that you can sit down
and focus for an hour or two and think
about something and I think writing is a
very effective to help it effective way
to help you think deeply so that's all I
have all I have for you today
and if you if there's anything you need
to remember it is the github link
github.com /ox to do slash blog down
that's where you can find the broadband
package as well as the blog handbook so
remember I still not complete you might
struggle with this book but it should
get you started very easy so remember
that link and I think that's all I have
for today and I hope you can enjoy the
lockdown package as well as you're on
the website so I'll be ready to take
your questions
if I'm not able to answer all your
questions you can ask them on Stack
Overflow later with it tags are in
lockdown
thank you do you recommend using iframe
if wanting to embed a shiny app into a
post absolutely yeah if you have a shiny
app I think they I would strongly
recommend you to use a friend
typically I don't I don't I don't like
iframes but I don't I don't think
there's a better option for shiny
applications our files using dot MD
extension and dad are MD extension or
either yeah you can you can use either
one your post can be either don'tdon't
MD or dot our MD the difference is that
the taught MD the pure markdown files
will become hired by hugo using black
friday but the dot our MD files will be
compiled through blog on our tongue and
pen doc so the markdown syntax is
slightly different but you can use
either one if you if you want to write
something about our if you have any
computation in your post you will you
will have to use our mountain instead of
Martin's so someone asked is it better
than Jekyll um well III think I have to
clarify a little bit about the
preference between Jaco and Hugo so
basically if you're if you are
comfortable with Jaco right now if
you're comfortable with your website I
would recommend you to stay with Jake on
I switch to Jacko as it I switch to Hugo
as I said the main reason is that jackal
is too slow for me and I hated the
dependency how so
but for now there's no native oh wow I
should say there's no support from me to
you right our motto is Jericho but I did
have I did have an experiment like in
2014 which where I tried to combine a
jackal knitter but still I personally I
don't quite recommend and you to look at
this country but I would recommend you
to try and block them right away instead
of hacking through my outer hip hot
stream neither Jenko I should say is as
possible but it's not very
straightforward it's certainly not as
streamlined as in Blanca okay so is it
possible to show tanks or categories
with a Hugo lithium theme and the answer
is yeah of course it is possible yeah
oh well I should say that my currently
my personal preferences preferences that
I I don't I don't want to use tanks or a
category that but I know most people
will use them and I should say it is
possible to support tanks and categories
and in to do that you have to learn a
little bit about the Hugo templating
syntax and go to the documentation of
Hugo and then I will show you where we
can find the information so basically
yeah I think that the section that we
need to read is is this taxonomy
taxonomy is yeah that is where we can
find information or what a better way is
that you can you can go you can find a
theme that actually supports tags and
categories and you can the study is
source code of the templates and you can
I think it should be able to figure out
how to and attacks and categories
support to their abilities Timothy if
you cannot figure that out feel free to
file a feature request to block them and
I can take a look at that so someone
asked how to get the RSS link that can
be used to add to that can be used at
the blog blog to bloggers website yeah
so for all the Hugo so for all Hugo
websites there will be an RSS file so
for example for my own website there is
that index dot XML file so that is the
RSS link that you can use to add to our
bloggers so basically you can go to any
sub directory of your website for
example you go to my English posts
directory and then at index dot XML and
this will be the RSS feed for my English
blog posts yeah so basically the thing
to remember is the file is named index
dot XML
[Music]
you